When I met her, I knew with certainty...
...that I wanted to travel the world with her forever.
That hasn't changed.
My hair, however, certainly has.
We climbed Kilimanjaro together.
We purchased tickets on a whim and moved to Korea.
We bought a secondhand motorcycle together and we traveled.
I remember watching her eyes light up...
...when we trained falcons in Bahrain...
...or explored the hidden corners of the globe,..
....and that was everything to me.
With each new trip, we found out more about the world and each other.
When I proposed at the Taj Mahal,...
...did so because all I wanted was to travel the world with her forever.
Ours was a love story written in arrival and departure dates.
Love notes signed to seat assignments 4A and 4B.
You learn so much in traveling with someone,...
...not only about them, but about yourself.
Each new adventure lets our love for one another and the world grow...
...and I didn't think we could ever find a journey more exciting than that.